oh shoot this is happening oh come
on caitlyn i know you were nervous you
had said that
to watch it all back what was it like
yeah i think anybody would be nervous to
relive those moments it's such a unique
experience and once it's done you're
like okay it's done
it's not gonna happen anymore we're not
gonna relive it and then boom we're
reliving it
um so uh i actually got a screener of it
so i was able to watch and it took me
about three days to get through
everything uh
and it was it was fun it was sad it was
funny it was empowering it was a bunch
of different emotions
through the whole thing does that mean
you'd watch it for 10 minutes then you
needed a little break
yeah okay a line break did you tell them
who you watched
oh yeah let's do it with jason's mom
she's my support system
i'm giving you the the best future
mother-in-law award right
here right now she i'm gonna get her a
big
trophy yes we had a great time together
watching his shoes
she passed using wine i was gonna say
how much
how much wine did you pour for her
that's why
we don't numbers she watched the show we
all know it was five years ago
yeah and so it was kind of like we'll
just watch it together and she even said
something so sweet like just don't think
of me as jason's mom through this
and i was like okay you don't think
about me as jason's girlfriend
wow friends watch the bachelor my mom's
been a fan of the show forever
so when i went on the show her friend i
told her that i was being recruited by
the show she goes oh hell no
this is my escape from your my family
everyone this is my territory
stay the hell out now the world has
collided not only was i on the show
got off it then caitlin and i start
dating she's just like
what the hell's happening this this is
the future mother-in-law of the year
award
seriously yes jason i know you
had said you hadn't watched this season
before so i'm wondering if you watched
this episode and got the cliffs notes
yeah so i i watched it in a different
room i was
very reluctant i'm like you know what i
don't think i'm going to watch it
but at the end of the day one thing i
always preach is like you can't use
someone's history against them and to
know where someone came from and the
derivative
of that like puts them where they are
today and i think with caitlyn and i
whether it's good bad or ugly we just
have like clear communication of where
we stand
and so if i'm gonna be someone that like
preaches that it's
who am i to say oh i'm not gonna i'm
just gonna ignore it i'm not gonna pay
attention to it and they probably didn't
enjoy it yeah and well i think
emotionally like even when we found out
that it's rearing
we're just like what the hell it's
emotionally it sucks no one wants to see
that right but logically
what's the reality of the situation the
reality is without this show without
that experience
uh without me being on the show this
never happens ever right well now
if i don't get if i sling to your dms
just randomly would you respond
exactly so history
puts us where we are today and uh
today's a beautiful thing
you're friendly with a lot of guys from
katelyn's season what was it like to
watch
the woman you love make out with your
friends
it was uh it brought memories back to
when i was like single watching becca
season back and i'm just like you're
seeing all this you're just like
watching it like between your fingers um
it's it's weird right it's very weird
but at the end of the day like i i've
met ben
i met jared i met nick all these guys
before i actually met caitlin
and became friends with them before that
so you know what
when i think about those guys i think
about like the friendship we have and i
try and uh
you know put this way behind us
what also really helps too is i wasn't
on the season right i think
not being on the season and not knowing
all the dynamics is totally
uh helps at part of my lives but uh it's
it's certainly strange
what was just your feeling watching it i
i know it was hard but did you look back
and and kind of have a reflective
summary of your season
honestly watching back i i just like i
said earlier it was
so many different emotions that i can't
even
comprehend like what exactly i felt
through the whole thing
it was more yeah oh my gosh i didn't
remember that happened
oh i'm really proud of myself for that
oh god you could do that
like it was just a bunch of different
things but overall i felt like
from where we were then to where we are
now
um as a society it i feel
i was just feeling kind of proud of
myself i remember you got into on your
tell-all
uh chris harrison and you addressed the
horrible comments that you were getting
from people were you apprehensive that
that might happen again now from people
yeah i think i think what i'm most
nervous for
with the whole season re-airing is the
critiques that will come along with it
um and i know there will still be people
out there that don't agree
and that are going to say nasty things
it's already started on twitter
the nasty comments have already started
but i feel like at this point
the the supporters are louder and
and it's come such a far away that i'm
just
i'm just happy that we've gotten to a
point where there are still those people
but i
i don't even have to say anything to
them anymore because there's so many
empowering women that will stand up for
me in those comments anyways
and the show has just come so far and i
think
so have uh the viewers it's wild to look
back and think about how many people
then had a problem
with a woman owning her sexuality in a
relationship
you look back and think not just how
much have you changed but how much
times have changed yeah that's i mean
and that was another thing i was hoping
for you know with having a black
bachelor
lead is that it was about time we all
have been saying this for so long
because the show has done such a good
job at evolving over the years with
talking about even i think we heard some
religion talk on the last season
um important conversations around like
how you would spend money i think is a
conversation people are starting to have
now
important things that matter in a
relationship people being intimate with
each other and now
you know it was just only it was a
no-brainer to also you know evolve as a
show in that way
your hair is so brown on your season you
know
i was like a little baby i was like look
at our baby face and that dark dark
brown hair
you know we got all these highlights now
that was actually part of one of the
easiest things about watching i'm like
is that caitlyn
i know nick and i joked that we both got
glow-ups
oh nick mick had
nick having a beard in his life now it
was a good choice
you mentioned watching stuff and
remembering it
what did you watch that you had
forgotten happened i
i forgot how awful that breakup was with
nick
i thought i was like sorry man there's
someone else like i didn't realize it
was such
a long conversation and i like felt so
terrible that he was so blindsided i
think i'd convince myself that i was
like
yeah it's not gonna work out bye and
then i watched it and i was like
oh my gosh i'm a monster
and everyone thought like why did
caitlyn let him just keep going and keep
talking and
i just kept letting him say exactly what
he was feeling and
i i was torn back and forth on do i let
him talk and have that
opportunity to say what he was really
feeling and wanting to say or do i cut
him off
right off the bat and like not give him
that opportunity and i went back and
forth and i decided to and he actually
thanked me later for doing that and he
said it was really
important for him that i did let him
speak but that's the part i totally
forgot
he said on the recap that he he wanted
to push you in the pool
it would have been hilarious that would
have been so funny if he pushed me in
the pool
i don't i don't know if jason agrees
it's like no everything i'm looking for
is there
i'm falling in love with you we did not
relive the sean proposal that was not in
the episode what happened with
this episode coming to light i actually
thought and i think i was
told that that proposal would happen
remember i told you i was like i think
they're airing the proposal
yeah um so i was actually shocked too
when they didn't show it
because i was expecting to see that i
was kind of preparing myself
for that um so yeah i was surprised they
didn't
i mean they interviewed a lot of people
from my season
so i don't know if they just were like
we can't do one more interview
or just maybe the fact that they were
respecting this relationship
where after they knew they were coming
straight to us and
that can you know sometimes just be well
i mean let's be real this whole
was there a moment watching this back
that brought you to tears
oh yeah three times i think i cried
because it wasn't i was like
like miss these people it was so
overwhelming if i get overwhelmed with
emotion i'll just cry
and i think just watching it even the
beginning
um limo entrances i started crying just
because i haven't been able to go back
and watch any of it and i haven't
relived that since it was in the present
moment
so to go back that long ago and just
i could almost like smell the mansion
and like
remember exactly how it went down and
everything just came rushing back
because i think i've been blocking it
out for so long
that i was just overwhelmed with emotion
watching it and
there were so many you know special
moments and fun moments and hilarious
moments and sad moments that
just the emotion was taking over and
i just i cried yeah about three times
you said
in a really great moment that night at
the mansion that it was the best moment
of your life
to find out you'd been named the
bachelorette we saw you call your mom
you were so happy you've had a lot of
great moments since then i was wondering
would you still call that the best
moment of your life it was up there i
mean it was just such a surreal moment
because i never would have thought i was
gonna be the bachelorette coming off the
bachelor
i was the third to go home and i was
like there's no way
i am not who they pick as the
bachelorette you know
edgy canadian tattoos potty mouth like
not the girl next door didn't even cross
my mind that that was going to be an
option
so when they had asked me i was like oh
my gosh i'm so honored and then they
said oh but we're putting you against a
woman and then i was like oh and then
they're going that wasn't great
but then once chris sat me down and said
like you are
our next bachelorette i just remember
being like this is a pivotal moment in
my life that i will never
forget and there was so much build up
towards it it was just something i never
imagined could happen for me and so it
is still up there as
one of the best moments of my life
especially calling my mom after
and just feeling so excited well we we
almost got what we thought maybe was
going to be
another best moment of your life it
wasn't a ring box it was air pods um
like the look on youtube's faces you
both looked paralyzed with fear
jason were you thinking oh crap she
thinks i'm gonna propose
well the i mean full backstory still in
a little t
here they actually came to me asking me
if i'd like to take this opportunity to
propose
and um after thinking through it and no
form was there any pressure just like
hey if you think this is the right time
we're here to support it
we'll take care of it make it special
and i didn't even bring it up
i shot it down after about a day of
thinking because
i'm just like listen this is a part of
her history a part of
our story is next we don't need these
stories to align
the same showing etc so i shot it down
but i told caitlyn after i said hey i
want to let you know
they came to me i did decline it she's
like thank gosh i wouldn't want
that to be then either so right after
it's like i break up with nick then i
getting
sean no way
so but the funny thing is is when
caitlyn felt by you're
the irony of the fact that i have like a
nice dress shirt and literally
in pants on because you can't see blower
wigs with ear pods at 9 pm
on my left pocket and you felt that i'm
like well of course she knows because we
already talked about this but
i think the emotions get here like oh my
god